so why does this movie resonate with so
many people in other words what's it
about glad you asked STM plays Adam clay
who lives a quiet Life as a rural
beekeeper he looks after his hives and
is a great neighbor to an older lady
named Eloise sadly Eloise Falls victim
to an online scam and loses a bunch of
money and even more tragically she kills
herself because of it we see that
there's a massive operation of criminals
whose entire business plan is to fool
elderly people into giving their money
anyway and as you probably know this is
something that is happening more and
more in real life so as you might expect
Statham's character decides it's time to
take this organization out not only to
avenge his friend but also to stop them
from scamming other innocent people and
the rest is a back and forth of him
being a badass and trying to stomp out
the evildoers